what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so getting into the Sinestro Corps war
aftermath this is really kind of like an
epilogue slash prologue or pre lute and
the reason why is because we're most
writers and for those of you guys who
are new to comics most writers will
usually write like a crossover event or
some huge story arc and then they'll
stop and they'll just do like some
small-time story or something like that
there's something that doesn't really
tie into anything and it's just kind of
fair what geoff johns did for the whole
entirety of Green Lantern is one story
arc to conclusion of a story arc would
lead into the beginning of another story
arc and so this basically goes into
blackest night because remember blackest
line is the whole idea of like these
emerging lantern quarters and so on and
a scraping huge war and in all those
seven things so it was cool for what it
was but it was basically this great big
huge conflict and so a lot of the
different a lot of the things that we're
going to see between now in the time we
start blackest night here in the next an
illuminating month or so a couple months
these things will all basically go into
the event of the blackest night story
itself so what this does is this picks
up again with the aftermath of Sinestro
Corps war and in the last video when we
have done that Sinestro Corps war we had
talked about how it was really the first
major emergence of the yellow lanterns
the first major emergence of Sinestro
forming his own Lantern Corps and I
remember where the Green Lantern's
basically derived their power from the
will aspect of the emotional spectrum
which is to say the ability to overcome
fear the Sinestro Corps derives their
power from fear and so long as their
spear in the universe so long as there's
a singular being that experiences fear
or is afraid of something then the
Sinestro Corps will always have power
because again they derive their power
from the emotional spectrum just this
infinite source of emotion as long as
there is a being alive in the universe
there will be different forms of
emotions and so again with this whole
idea what we know is that the Sinestro
Corps rings are still going out and
seeking hosts they're still trying to
find people who could be viable
candidates to become members of the
Sinestro Corps and that's really one of
the basis or one of the biggest ideas of
this is that Sinestro set it up so that
should he be defeated the Corps will
continue to grow and so the idea is that
while this is happening we actually pick
up with Kyle Rayner and Guy Gardner now
remember Kyle Rayner and Guy Gardner is
part of the Green Lantern Corps do their
own thing for the most part but the
Green Lantern Corps line of stories ran
side-by-side with the main Green Lantern
stories in the sins of the Green Lantern
Corps just focused on the other
core members what the other members
outside of how Jordan were basically
doing and the funny thing about this is
it's basically guy gardner and kyle
rayner taking off and intending to live
on OA and then guy gardner wanting to
open a bar and it's kind of a funny
scenario because remember ah these
characters come from their own
backgrounds they come from their own
Heritage's their own stories and for the
most part they've all lost a lot of
different things Kyle Rayner more so
than most corners girlfriends have all
been killed you know he lost his mother
to a parasite that was basically a
member of the Sinestro Corps
you know they've all lost different
things and so leaving planet Earth and
taking up residence on OA serves two
purposes the first is that within the
confines of the Green Lantern mythos it
gives Kyle Rader and Guy Gardner their
own stories their own adventures they
can go out on and do their own thing but
the other half of this is that it
actually sets the stage for future
events later on with regards to why it
is that they're in space as opposed to
Hal Jordan who's spending some of its
time on earth so again it's really
setting the stage for a lot of the
things that we will see later on down
the line when it comes to the Green
Lantern mythos now at this point we pick
up with Mongol who is the son of Mongol
which is kind of weird the first
or as is usually referred to Mongol one
it's basically like this pre-crisis on
Infinite Earths character that served
the purpose of just being a major foe of
Superman the idea though was that with
this version of Mongol basically Mongol
- as a lot of people call him he made
his emergence in 1995 with the showcase
line of stories I think it was and I
want to say the showcase stories in the
mid 90s are basically stories that were
designed to literally showcase different
villains and heroes and someone and so
forth but the idea is that the original
Mongol that helped to destroy ko City
which set in motion the idea of how
Jordan be you know being possessed by
parallax and then becoming a villain and
so on and so forth ah what Mongol to did
is he basically followed up with his
father's grand schemes of trying to
either defeat the Justice League or
defeat Superman or something along those
lines but he basically became a villain
now his big claim to fame was having a
helping hand and Superman you know
basically being prepared for the
invasion of imperiex and in fury actions
of course basically DC's version of
Galactus I mean that there's really no
way to say it I mean that's pretty much
what he was but the idea is that despite
a few instances here and there when
Mongol has helped out Superman they
basically become unwilling allies due to
a common enemy that was stronger than
both of them individually for the most
part Mongol is just always
then a bad guy and so what ended up
happening here at least what is it
taking place here is that Mongol is
bestowed with a yellow Lantern ring now
remember this makes sense because when
it comes to the yellow lantern rings
they're designed to instill fear and we
saw during the Sinestro Corps war that
like anti-monitor and hank henshaw
cyborg superman that superboy-prime
these various individuals had basically
been imbued with a yellow Lantern ring
because of the fact they were able to
instill so much fear and individual
people Mongol is much the same way the
difference here is that he actually has
kind of an ace up his sleeve a really
cool really cool hat trick that actually
works really well for the purpose that
he serves now again Gary back to Kyle
Rayner and in guy gardner with the whole
idea of the story humor is kind of an
important aspect of the Green Lantern
mythos especially with what's coming
later on down the line because things
are going to get really really dark
no pun intended when blackest night
rolls around things will get really dark
like it'll be it'll be really kind of
crazy but again for these guys it's a
matter of just kind of trying to make a
way for themselves you know trying to
make their own little home of you know
home away from home and taking up
residence on OA now remember this is not
unprecedented there are people who
simply just reside on OA Kilowog for
example resides on OS alot resides on
Owen these different members of the the
Green Lantern mythos of course Kilowog
basically being the drill sergeant for
the Green Lantern Corps and cilok being
the voice of the guardians of the
universe it makes sense that they would
reside on OA buffer Guy Gardner and Kyle
Rayner they can really serve or really
have the best use when they're on OA and
the reason for this is because of the
fact to remember with regards to the
Green Lantern's the most part earth is
the only planet that really has like
four different Green Lantern's you've
got Kyle Rayner you've got John Stewart
you've got Guy Gardner and you've got
Hal Jordan you don't need for it
you really only need two and so again we
have Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan back on
earth and we've got Guy Gardner and Kyle
Rayner you know out in space now the
other half of this is remember Mongol is
as intelligent as he is powerful and
that's one of the things that makes him
so dangerous is because he is so capable
and so where some individuals would have
you know would have received a yellow
lantern ring and then would have
immediately just like jumped out into
the fray sort of fighting Green
Lantern's or something along those lines
Mongol takes a far different approach
instead he basically has a lantern race
in 96 hours giving him all the
information to the Lantern ring knows
and so over the course of the 72 hour
window
had learned about the origin of the
sinestro rings he learned about the
history of Sinestro himself he learned
about the Green Lantern's he learned
about the blackest night prophecy he'd
learned all these different things
basically everything we've covered up to
this point he was given all that
information within wouldn't you know
really like 96 hours or 72 72 hours
wherever the case may be and so the
result is that the guardians of the
universe began to realize that all these
different Sinestro Corps rings are
basically taking off to the Vega system
and the result is that they begin
calling back together all these
different members of the Green Lantern
Corps now for those of you guys who have
read ahead please do not spoil anything
about the Vega system because I know
what you're thinking do not spoil
anything about the Vega system but what
I will say is there's actually a reason
why the Green Lantern's are not supposed
to go to the Vega system it's actually a
really cool basis behind that but the
funny thing about this is that they're
actually instructed to do so now again
we'll get into that once we get into
like the whole you know pre Leda
blackest night and different things like
that but the idea here is that for the
guardians of the universe well there
have been treaties and so on that have
been struck over the course of their
existence with different races and
groups that exist across the universe
occasionally the guardians of the
universe will violate those treaties and
the reason for that is because the
threat is just that credible and so
there's two things going on here the
first is that these Sinestro Corps rings
are disappearing to the far side of the
universe and to some individuals who are
being given Sinestro Corps rings are
just dying all of a sudden and nobody
knows why but what we end up doing is we
transition back to and what we end
up finding out here is that Mangal
themself is basically traveling around
to these different individuals who have
been who have been given Sinestro Corps
rings and offers them two options the
first is to either serve Mangal or the
second is to die and a lot of them just
refused they simply refuse to serve
Mangal because remember the Sinestro
Corps rings bond themselves to what are
basically bullies and so if you're a
person that's been more or less
dominating a local village or a small
territory or something along those lines
and then suddenly a semestre core ring
appears to you what you're going to do
what you do best you're just going to
start bullying people and then if
somebody else comes along and says you
work for me now well of course you're
going to resist that the difference here
is that we have a guy who's basically on
par with Superman in a lot of ways who's
now been given a Sinestro Corps ring and
so these average bad guys out there
these average bullies who have dominated
these little towns or something like
that while the yellow lantern ring does
give them a whole host of abilities they
have neither
the brains nor the the forethought to be
able to use them effectively and they're
easily dominated by Mangala so the
result is that he's been going around
killing these different Sinestro Corps
members and then taking their rings now
what this does is it basically picks up
with the idea of these different
individuals who are being sent out in
groups for the purpose of tracking down
these rings and what it is is happy with
these people now also remember soda
yacht is now I on of course if you
missed the last video so to me out was
this character who is basically
introduced as a what-if scenario like
what if Superman got a Green Lantern
ring because soda yacht descends from a
group that are basically called Dax
amides but they are a branch off of
traditional Kryptonians and so when
exposed to a Yellow Sun suddenly sodam
yacht has all the powers of Superman
combined what Dave with a Green Lantern
ring now the reason why he's I on the
distinction between ion and a regular
Lantern is that sodam yacht is basically
imbued with pure will power would be ion
entity and of course the ion entity is
the physical manifestation of the
emotion of willpower so again that's how
all this stuff really kind of comes
together and we'll see that more over
the course of the Green Lantern mythos
sort of course parallax the entity that
represents fear that you know again ion
is the entity that represents will and
will see things like the bowl which is
the entity that represents your rage for
the Red Lantern cores and so on and so
forth but the fact remains here that
would I on and ERISA I think it is that
are basically traveling to you know
these different lantern locations and so
on and so forth the other members of the
Lantern Corps are coming across these
basically like these giant body parts
limbs and so on that belonged to just
different members of the Sinestro Corps
who were defeated who are dismembered so
on and so forth only for us to find out
mongol is captured of ryssia and n sodam
yacht and is basically bestowed upon
them these black mercy plants now
remember these are black mercy plants or
what it is that makes Mongols such a
dangerous foe and differentiates him
from the other members of really the
Sinestro Corps really any other villain
that exists out there in the realm of DC
Comics and the reason why I say this is
because you remember the black mercy
plants as we talked about in our DC
rebirth video about Trinity basically
were bonded to a host and in turn that
host would enter this kind of dream
state they were basically experience
this whole this whole illusion with no
real idea of what was going on around
them and so the result of this is that
we actually end up finding out they're
with ERISA and with with sort of yacht
being taken away that
Emily it's supposed to be this kind of
happy experience you go through these
dreams and you have these incredible
experiences you basically live out this
almost perfect life but instead a
whiskey and soda yacht or experiencing
absolute nightmares and so again this is
kind of a cool moment because what this
does is it basically comes back and it
goes to the faces behind the mercy plan
it's its origin how it all comes
together so on and so forth and so what
the other Green Lantern's are able to
jump in you know and rescue sodam yada
and rescue Alyssa again it's basically
this idea that there's like this mother
mercy more or less I guess this black
mercy prime so to speak that's giving
birth to all these different plants that
Mongols been using and so what we end up
finding out here is that we're Mongols
going through and again basically taking
all these black mercy seedlings firing
them you know into the universe for the
purpose of just more or less taking
people over that he's essentially gone
through and modified or at least he's uh
benefiting from these modified black
mercy plants in the sense that the black
mercy plants where they're supposed to
instill people with you know happy
experiences and instead are forcing them
to experience a massive amount of fear
the overarching goal of mongol is to
basically force everybody in the
universe to feel here and in turn
empower himself with this virtually
unrivaled level of power that nobody
else could begin to grasp and so the
result is that what the Green Lantern's
go through and they start freeing so the
me out and so on and so forth that the
back a black mercy plant basically
speaks directly to them the mother mercy
plant basically says that originally it
was designed for the purpose of making
death and easy passage that those beings
who experienced death getting ready to
pass over they would basically be imbued
with these plants and they wouldn't
experience the horrific turning being
you know the horrific circumstances
under their own death meaning they
wouldn't suffer pain and different
things like that instead they would
basically pass on with no real impact on
what it is it was happening to them
instead
blended up happening is the first
Mangala come along and grab these black
mercy plants and then basically started
screwing with them and sort of modifying
them and turning into the turn them into
something that could be used for evil
and so the result is that he intends to
again basically blanket the universe and
fear and empower himself now the reason
why this story matters so much so the
reason why this is such an important
aspect is because again much like the
stories that we saw where you know you'd
have like Hal Jordan most wanted kind of
this one-off story that existed out
there by themselves what this also does
is it basically lays the groundwork for
the rise of the star sapphires because
remember this star sapphires are
basically
Lantern cores that deal with love they
believe love is an extreme thing we had
talked about how Carol Farris Abita had
been transformed into a star sapphire
and then she was eventually freed from
its control this is going to see them
come back and it's going to see them
being one of the other Lantern cores
that are starting to rise to prominence
and so again it's these small little
things that are written into this story
it's these small little moments where we
basically have this great big huge event
it doesn't really seem to tie in to
anything and then it's just this little
tidbit much like we saw with our
previous Lantern videos you know where
it was basically two Justice League
fighting alongside the Green Lantern and
getting some force and then suddenly a
Sinestro Corps ring suddenly appears to
Bruce Wayne and says you know look you
know Bruce Wayne you have the ability to
instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and then
eventually just kind of abandons them
you know after realizing he had to use a
Green Lantern ring but the fact remains
here that what the Green Lantern is able
to overcome these black mercy plants and
effectively defeating mongold this leads
to his character just kind of being kept
in stasis and being kept on the back
burner and the reason why is because
once we start to get into the whole
element of blackest night different
things like that that he'll actually
make a return that he'll actually end up
coming back and the result is that he'll
play a more significant role in the
different stories that we see leading
into blackest night and so on and so
forth now the other half of this is the
again you know mother mercy planted
herself in the sense that she's actually
inducted into the Green Lantern Corps
because of the fact that she has the
ability to lean to both sides
but the black mercy plants have the
ability to force people to experience
utter fear and at the same time give
people the ability to overcome fear
she's basically given a choice if she
can choose a yellow Lantern wing or she
can choose a Green Lantern ring and then
the result is that she ends up choosing
a Green Lantern ring and joining the
Green Lantern Corps but again this is
really the end of the story I mean if
there's not a whole lot here not a great
big huge set of events you know a
villain that was that's obscure to most
people who don't read comic books gets a
yellow Lantern ring for a little while
and then is ultimately defeated but
again it's these moments if these small
little panels these small little
segments these stories that don't seem
wildly interesting that become important
later on down the line and that's what
we're covering them because normally I
would have just skipped over this it
wouldn't have been important it would
have served no real purpose but we'll
reference back to these things we'll
talk about how mongrel got a Lantern
ring will make you know make reference
to these particular circumstances so
that way people won't feel left out to
be able to go back and watch the videos
and see what we're talking about and
that kind of a thing but in any event if
you guys are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob course you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]